they've come mostly from mariupol
evacuated by russia to russia when there
was no other way to leave
small groups of ukrainian refugees
hoping to move on to europe helped along
their way by volunteers like father
grigory russians with big hearts and an
open mind
sasha and angela from mariupol are both
blind
then sasha tells us this hopeful maybe
that someone somewhere can help
a 23 year old girl lost like so many
others in the ruins of mariupol
many of them have no money or they have
no
any sort of goods or any sort of gadgets
to organize
anything just to buy tickets for trade
so we buy tickets we
use
our
[Music]
all sort of our activities to help them
to go there where they want and it's
donations from russian people that mean
that you're able to
pay for the tickets and get yours
yes yes no it's only
only russians
in the hustle and bustle of saint
petersburg they blend in these brother
nations turned on one another by the
kremlin's tales of denarcification
but early morning you can find small
groups waiting for their transfers the
next leg in long journeys out of the
country that's bombing theirs
another family of six million who have
now fled ukraine's borders in these last
three months some petersburg's governor
has just announced that this city will
be twinned with mariupol or what's left
of it after what the russians call a
liberation that so many of those
millions never asked for
at this aid center in moscow you'll find
mostly the pro-russian ukrainians who
are happy to stay
[Music]
the focus now of russia's donbass
offensive thinks that the only way
she'll see her husband again is if
russia takes the town
the talk here is of nazis that ukraine
is using civilians as human shields
people who fled donbass who believe what
russian tv tells them
ukraine
will help any refugee whatever they
believe
but with her organization designated a
foreign agent
she remembers the wars in chechnya when
the rage of soldiers mothers as the
death toll climbed changed public
opinion but she doesn't see that
happening
these ukrainians making their way out
know that they want no part of a system
that would wipe out 30 years of freedoms
even if what they really want is to
return to homes and lives which no
longer exist
dinah magnay sky news saint petersburg